- Well, we've found one of
your first casting shots.
Let's put it up here.
This,
(laughing)
this is like rock and roll.
Like this is like, is this
your Joan Jett, The Cure?
There's so many things
happening, I love it.
So did you get any work from these shots?
- So.
Look, my agent at the time was
like, we need some pictures.
I was like, sure.
You know,
I was like rolling with
whatever people were telling me.
I was like, this is gonna be great.
Obviously I wasn't auditioning
to be in boy bands at the time,
so it didn't help me
get any work,
(audience laughs)
but I got to use the sauna at the hotel,
so I got like a nice spa day from it.
- I think you look cool.
I think from that picture though,
I was like, I would've
pegged you as a musician,
not an actor.
I was like, she definitely
plays music.
- Yeah, but also
I sent a selfie to someone
yesterday and they were like,
"Oh, I thought that was Harry Styles."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Well, he's gorgeous.
See, you're even pretty as a boy.
So, you don't actually have the force,
or maybe you do and you're hiding it.
But is it true that you
do have a witchy sense?
- Yes.
People say I have, witchy senses,
I'm quite, I think they call them USP,
ultra sensitive person, right?
I tend to be able to read
people's moods quite well
to a point that people
comment on it often.
- Oh, you're an empath.
Like you're kind of,
- Yeah.
But I think everyone sort of is,
if they will open to it,
I just think I'm quite
watchful, so I notice things.
But yes, an empath, I guess.
- I am like that.
That's why everybody makes
fun of me because I cry a lot.
And I'm like,
I feel what everyone's feeling.
Like if someone's nervous,
if someone is angry,
I am like a sponge for people's feelings.
And I think it's kind of nice
because you, I don't know,
I think it makes you an empathetic person,
so you can put yourself
in someone's shoes easily,
but at the same time, it's
kind of, it's exhausting.
So yeah.
- It is exhausting.
And I think on the question
of the Chaos Walking too,
I already find it tiring
enough when I'm like
dealing with my own
neuroses as we all have.
And then like you're picking
up on other people's moods
and you're being affected by that.
Like, if you were to have that next level
and hear people's thoughts,
like that's heavy.
I don't want that on my shoulders.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Was there ever a moment,
like you felt like it was too much
when you were around
someone and you were like,
ooh, you could feel it so much
that you just had to tell them?
- Hm, I don't think so.
But I will tell you the,
on the subject of senses,
'cause it's not just
senses with other people,
there was this joke that
I went whale watching
and I went, "Ooh!"
and a whale came out of the sea.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] What?
- I'm not joking, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, so one time I
was on a safari in Africa
and it was like our first time
and we were in the truck
and we literally headed out the gates
in Sabi Sands in Kruger National Park,
And I was like, "Queue the lion."
And like literally
within like five minutes,
I spotted a female lion
that led us to like a whole pride of lions
with baby lions, little cubs.
And then they stole and ate Paula's food.
And I was like, that
was rude, but whatever.
But no, I've done something like that.
That's amazing though.
So you're kind of like Nemo as well.
You do have superpowers.
I like it.
Well, since you're from London,
I have to ask you about,
you know, British pub life.
I love a British pub, by the by,
but have you ever worked at the pub?
- Yes, I've worked at two.
One, not so fun,
was a bit of a drag.
The second, really enjoyed it.
And they had a five pound
burger on a Wednesday.
So it was always great,
'cause we always got a
burger when we were working.
- That's amazing, that's a big burger.
That's very Texan of you.